today I want you to stand up so I'm in
Madrid this week I've been doing a
presentation keynote and sashes out
librarians stay relevant and I haven't
had a lot of time to really work on the
book this week but I did get my version
into the publisher and it's being
reviewed and some feedback came back and
the initial run the feedback i took
really carefully and did a lot of work
to fix and improve the book and a lot of
what I agreed with and some of it I
didn't but I was still okay with it I
think it'll make a better book but there
are two things now that I'm fighting for
there are two things that have to be in
the book that the publisher doesn't want
in the book but has to be in the book
and it's like a walk away like this has
to be in the book and I will see how we
handle it because for me the book
doesn't exist without these two things
its core to what the book is all about
and some fight for it hard there is
you're talking yourself iron man this is
Skip president of the organization that
was here Hugh Bravo are you coming to
dinner today I am NOT okay okay here's
man cheers
that was cool these two things that have
to be in the book that if it's not in
the book that's it you know I don't know
what's going to happen and so as a
entrepreneur you have to understand and
take a stance on things to you want to
take feedback from the people but when
you feel that you're right about
something when you feel like in your gut
you believe in something you believe all
the way then don't let people talk you
out of it and I think sometimes we let
our customers we let our suppliers we
let investors walk on us a little bit
too much where you should got to stand
up for something and anyway I'm excited
we'll see what happens with the fight
and i'll keep you guys updated as we go
so let's get to the questions okay first
question came in from readers
congratulations Evan who is your
publisher I had no idea your Canadian
let's go Blue Jays let's go I love the
Jays I mentioned him in my conversation
today in my talk because the Toronto
library did an awesome job covering the
Blue Jays so try to repertory wherever I
go my publisher is penguin Random House
and I've talked about this a couple
times but my literary agent basically
lined up a bunch of meetings with a
bunch of publishers had five meetings in
two days all kind of back to back to
back and they asked me questions they
wanted my pitch and we had a couple of
offers we had three offers i believe and
then made it down to one and so penguin
Random House was the winner also I
really like the team there I felt like
they understood the book when I was
trying to do where I think a lot of the
other ones just one of the partner with
me but weren't a fan of the concept that
felt like this wasn't a book was a
worksheet or a small guy but not a
full-length book it's like you guys
don't get the vision like how can i
partner with somebody doesn't really
quite yet
vision and so there are still some
things as much as I complain about you
know the publisher and his two things
that I'm fighting for I was the best of
the publish that that that we could
choose from and I'm super excited to be
working with them next up Mel Mariposa I
stop this after two minutes because I'm
really struggling with my perfectionism
and this is like the opposite of what I
need to hear right now maybe someone can
recommend me stuff on commitment and
perfectionism as you can see I'm in the
streets of Madrid I forget what the
video was on and why you stopped it
after two minutes I think it was maybe
to do with being proud of what you're
creating what I've just told a gassy
perfectionism came your problem and I
have a perfectionist trait as well I
think it's one of those things where you
want to combine the genius at the end
where you want something that you're
proud of but you also want to get
something out because with perfectionist
people and I can be perfectionist to
like the book right like you could just
keep adding and editing and editing and
had anything that they never release
anything I think that's a challenge for
a lot of people's you keep working on
your idea and then you never actually
get anything out and doesn't doesn't
help achieve your goals I was just
trying to balance it I try to find that
balance where what you put out has to be
good and then just focus on making it
better like if you're trying to get on a
YouTube channel make your first video
you're going to suck it'll be a terrible
video it might be the best you can do at
that time and then focus the next video
making it better
better next video making it better and I
think as long as you're improving every
day it makes the perfectionist part go
away a little bit because you feel like
you're you're getting better and I don't
know if you can completely eliminate the
perfectionist gene and I know a lot of
people have that in them and I do
haven't been in me too but just for me
at least it helps to know what I'm
getting better every day and I'm working
on it and just get something out and
like that feels momentum getting
something now and getting feedback and
getting people using your thing watching
your videos vine your product just a few
you know like the butte youtube coverage
that I got really on when I was starting
my youtube hear that that was fuel for
me to keep going and by not releasing
anything you don't give yourself the
momentum that you get from other people
using your product or service so I think
you got to get it out get it out and
just keep making it better next up
rising phoenix i hope your second book
to be on YouTube entrepreneurship and
the power of self belief thanks for the
video we already talking on my second
book first one hasn't come out yet I
have two whole concepts for my next book
one would be really easy and I'm kind of
excited about and one would be a lot
more work and I'm very excited about
what I'm trying not to get too far ahead
of myself because I haven't even
finished my first book and released it
and market it i'm excited to promote the
first book and get it out because it's
been almost a year of writing writing
writing writing so I want to get that
out but the next book I have some ideas
I'm not dropping anything yet but I have
some ideas so that's it quickly for the
sweet guys thank you for the love and
support if you have a question about the
topic today which was you know standing
up for yourself if you have a question
but my book for the book writing process
leaving the comments below and I'll
answer your question on the next edition
of the book thank you guys so much for
watching have a great day team to
believe and I'll see you soon